can you take us to the first day as the
showrunner for home improvement what was
that like
how are you interacting with the writers
well I knew all the writers I had either
work with them in previous years or had
hired them myself and chances are if I
hired them myself I had worked with them
maybe on other shows so that was all
easygoing but you know home improvement
was like a juggernaut it was a huge show
and it was a huge responsibility to be
the showrunner and it was my first job
as a showrunner once I found out that I
had the job I had spent a ton of time
prepping for that firsthand job about
how I would handle it what I would do
what my approach to show running would
be and I was lucky because I had had a
good mentor the showrunner before me was
Elliott schoneman and he had a very
precise way of doing it and so I took a
lot from him and my goal in running a
show was to get people excited about
their own ideas everybody else's ideas
and really make it a fun room and when
you make it a fun room and you value the
other writers ideas great stuff can
happen and so because I had been in the
worst of writers rooms and the worst of
writers rooms go like this where they
have eight writers and one showrunner
the showrunner wants to rewrite
everything so that all the showrunner
wants is people around to spit out stuff
and and kind of tell them how great he
is and this happens way too often and at
the end of the day no matter how much
work they do in that room the showrunner
is going to take it home by himself and
rewrite every word and so you have a
demoralized staff I had no interest in
having the moralized staff I wanted
other people's contributions because in
comedy
that's what makes it better you know
just one person alone can really make it
as good as a group there are exceptions
this show fleabag is apparently written
by one person and she's very talented
but who knows maybe fleabag would be
even better if she had a staff you don't
know so how long we the showrunner for
office three years okay
and what was the latest you and your
group worked your team of writers you
know there would be occasional really
late nights and for me for us a really
late night might be midnight there are
rooms that go later than that and but we
always my kind of the thing that I
strove for is a showrunner
was no weekends no weekends in the room
because I had kids I had a wife I wanted
to spend time with them and when I was
doing shows even working for other
people I didn't really mind that much
working the late nights during the week
if I could get those two days off with
my family so that was that was important
would you also look at feedback from the
audience and how would you integrate oh
it was fantastic they had come up before
I even gone the show they had this whole
system now nobody else did this at the
time for the Wednesday run-through we
would read the script on Monday run
through the show on Tuesday afternoon
and then run through it again for the
network on Wednesday afternoon and when
we did our run-through we would bring in
20 people from the universal tour in
folding chairs to watch the run-through
so those those people told us what was
working and what wasn't working and then
by Thursday night camera run through the
show was in great shape and we were good
to go on Friday night how would they
deliver that would you sort of do a QA
let them afterwards he was all based in
their laughs it's all business
it's not hey you like this if they're
laugh and they like it that's true he
was fun it's not a sympathy laugh that
you could tell they were oh no you can
tell what's going on sure having worked
on other television shows you knew you
didn't want to quote demoralize of the
other writers I wanted to make them feel
a part of the process true so what were
you telling the fellow
on home improvement while you were the
showrunner well I tell them first of all
to come in with stories because that's
part of their job the main thing in a
show that I run or any show that is run
well is that nobody from your staff
should just shoot down an idea and say
that's not good
that is cardinal rule number one of
working on a television show comedy you
always have a fix and even if your fix
is not the final one or maybe not even
the best one that you're going to get to
if somebody says you know that jokes no
good that everybody's not going to last
in my room because that writer has to
pitch another joke that's their job or
if they don't like a story they need to
think of something that that they think
is better so in other words you just
don't be negative it's all you come at
it to be constructive so let's say we're
two writers and writers room and you
pitch a joke and say and then she
follows down at the end and instead if I
was thinking wow that's really bad
instead of me saying it I would be like
or if that's what if okay what if the
key two words are what it yeah because
that way you're not necessarily
insulting the last person who pitched
who might be insulted because they might
say oh wait a minute mine was great but
if they've got to understand that that
I'm coming into writers room people are
gonna have a lot of different ideas and
the what if is so much better than the
that sucks
so I would trade out the bad sucks for
the wife and so then how would the joke
went out if then another writer over
here said wait what if she does this or
whatever
at what point that's the showrunner job
you decide when it's good enough when
you like it and you know you you have to
be the final word so that really what it
really is what it means to be a showroom
somebody somebody has to have the final
word
and somebody's got to take the heat when
the network and the studio don't like
the show or the star doesn't like the
show so the showrunner makes a decision
and the star may say that sucks and then
you have to face the music how you're
going to fix that but that's part of the
gig did you ever get feedback what let's
suppose you wear the final say on the
joke and you thought it was great and
you were so proud and it backfired on
you and you got letters or people who
were upset you know when I did this it
was before you know Twitter and all this
stuff the letters went to the studios I
never saw the letters but you know we
would we would do a final pass the whole
room would do a final pass on a script
before it went to the actors at the
table on Monday and we turned in a
script that we thought was great the
actors could eat it the studio could
hate it the network anybody you know
because it's a subjective business
anybody can like or hate anything and
I've been on shows where the actors if
they read the script in advance or as
they're reading it at the moment if they
see a line they don't like they will
tank it so in other words they don't
even want this line to have a prayer of
winding up of the show so they read it
in such a way to make sure you know they
don't like it and that nobody at the
table laughs so so they sabotage it
crispin are you almost grateful that
social media that instant feedback
wasn't available or do you guess so yeah
no yeah I know I don't need social media
feedback for pretty much anything I mean
because remember we live in a world
today where everybody is a pundit okay
so you have you know millions and
millions of experts on what the United
States government should be doing and
what the president should be doing and
you know if you think about our lives
before social media you might read an
editorial by a really experienced column
this analyzing the situation and saying
you know here's what we should do and
then maybe the next week you read
something by another really
well-informed person saying you know I
don't think so
now we're getting advice from every
single person who has a phone and you
know what we don't need that we we have
plenty of experience and talented people
and it's great that everybody gets a
voice and a part of the conversation but
at a certain point it becomes like white
noise and and that's why so many people
get to a point they say we're turning it
off this week or we're turning it off
forever
I'm off Facebook I don't have a personal
page anymore or whatever and and they
just get burned out on it and if you
know and I've experimented with this and
not using it for a while and I would say
and they've done scientific studies that
people who get off social media are
happier so there you go
you